foreign
complexity characterizes statistical
zero knowledge
this is Joint work with Eric allender
and shuichi hirahara
so overview we'll go about the
preliminaries then the main results
followed by the proof sketches and then
on to the discussion section
information in a string
consider the following two phone numbers
on the left there is
98765-43210 and on the right we have
this strange looking number eight five
nine seven four two six one zero three
the question is which of these two phone
numbers is easier to recall
right you expect that the number on the
left because it has a clear pattern is
easier for us to remember as opposed to
the number on the right which looks kind
of random and that's basically the point
of what how much information a string
contains so we look at the string on the
left and it has lesser information and
hence is easier for us to remember as
opposed to the string on the right
to formalize this notion we have
kolmogorov complexity
the kolmogorov complexity of a string X
is essentially the size of the smallest
program description by
that
is such that the universal turing
machine you on this program description
outputs X
right so we consider a fixed Universal
turing machine U throughout the course
of the stock and our paper
and so the output U on Pi is a
well-defined output
the computational complexity of
establishing the coal mugger of
complexity of a given string X is
uncomputable
this is why various resource bounded
Notions of chromogorov complexity are
considered and because they are bounded
in resources
these versions of chronographer of
complexity are actually computable
um
computable problems
next languages versus Promise problems
well all of us know that languages have
a bunch of yes instances and a disjoint
bunch of no instances
well promise problems are very similar
except that they have yes instances a
disjoint bunch of no instances and they
also have a set of don't care instances
which we don't care about
right so a promise problem a is a pair
of disjoint sets of yes and no instances
a don't care instance of a is any string
that is not a yes or a no instance so a
language can be looked at as a promise
problem that has no don't care instances
what is the solution to a promise
problem well any set B such that the yes
instances of a are contained in B and
the no instances of a are contained in
the complement of B is a solution to a
given promise problem a
right so for a fixed promise problem we
can think of lots of solutions
um which play around with the fate of
the don't care instances
moving on
so the promise problem of interest to us
is the promised version of K complexity
which we will denote using r k
so the inputs here are
considered y of length m
the yes instances of r k have K
complexity at least half the length of
the string
the no versions of RK have K complexity
at most half the length of the string
but also with a subtracted error
function which would think of something
like log square m so the no instances
have K complexity at most M over 2 minus
log squared n
where e is the approximation error
function and for the course of the talk
you can consider e of M to be Theta of
log squared m
are results hold for all EFM satisfying
Es at least Omega log M and at most some
sub polynomial
so this is the promise problem
that we consider
next we look at randomized deductions so
randomized reductions generalize the
notion of a deterministic reduction
showed that sat reduces to Unique sat
under randomized reductions
further variance of minimum circuit size
problem and minimum core motor of Time
problem have been shown to be NP
complete under randomized reductions
whereas the same is not known for
deterministic reductions
in fact there are results showing that
fmcsp is shown to be NP complete under
deterministic reductions there are
significant complexity uh breakthroughs
so for the time being we just have to uh
be satisfied with this notion often be
completeness under randomized reductions
so what does a randomized reduction look
like so consider two promise problems A
and B
and let's look at the RP many one
reduction from A to B right so on the
left you have a yes instance don't care
instance and no instances of a
and
let M represent the reduction RPM RPM
minivan deduction from A to B right so M
takes us and put the instance X and it
takes some random string r
observe that the output M of x r is now
a distribution and not just a single
string
what uh is the fate of the distribution
well on the yes instances we required
that this distribution has probability
mass at least Theta
uh resulting in yes instances of B
with probability Mass
at most Epsilon and 1 minus Theta minus
Epsilon this Mema to know or don't get
instances of P
for the no instance of a we need that
with probability one M of x r is also a
no instance of P
right so this is what RP 21 reduction
looks like
here we have a definition of RP many one
reduction well a is RP when you want
reducible to B with threshold Theta if
there is a polynomial time turing
machine M satisfying the requirement of
the reduction as we have just seen so
yes instances mapped to yes instances
with probability at least Theta no
instances marked to no instances with
probability one
right and here we consider Theta to be
uh 1 minus 1 over n to the Omega 1 so
really Theta is very very close to 1.
observe that the error in the reduction
is 1 minus Theta and in this case it's
clear that this error is very small
similarly we also have what is called a
BPP many one reduction from A to B for a
BPP menu deduction from A to B
for both es and no instances the
constraints are the same
the reduction M of XR should result in
a yes instance for a yes instance with
probability at least Theta similarly on
a no instance you should generate a no
instance of B
with probability at least Theta and some
small amount of mass on the wrongly
generated outputs
again we look at the definition of bbp
21 reductions and it's the same idea a
yes instance Maps yes instance of a map
so as instance of p with probability at
least Theta I know instance of a maps to
a no instance of p with probability at
least Theta
okay now we come to statistical zero
knowledge
so
in regard when we try to understand this
class statistical zero knowledge we are
going to
not care too much about the main
definition itself instead we will look
at this complexity class from the
Viewpoint of its complete problems
but for the sake of uh
completion uh to help a little bit with
understanding what this class is we have
given a slide dedicated to the
definition so consider an all powerful
all all powerful proverb p
and a randomized polynomial time machine
V and another randomized polynomial time
machine machine s which represents the
verifier and the simulator
right so we have approver a verifier and
a simulator with these restrictions
the language l or a promise problem p is
in sck if
well on a given input whether X is in L
is determined by looking at
whether or not the verifier accepts x
with high probability based on a
transcript that the prover and the
verifier share so prover and verifier
interact on this input X and some shared
Randomness and the transcript of it is
fed to the verifier which has to accept
or reject based on whether X is in the
language
as for the zero knowledge part for only
those instances where X is in the
language we require that the output of
the simulator denoted by S of x r Prime
is statistically close to the transcript
PV of XR that the proverb and verifier
interact
right so these two distributions are
required to be statistically closed for
the case when X is in L and that uh is
what the zero knowledge guarantee for L
looks like
foreign
circuits that encode distributions
how does a circuit encode a distribution
well consider a circuit that takes M
bits of input and prints out n Bits of
output based on some computation
we observe that
on the uniform Distribution on M bits C
outputs or probability distribution on 0
1 to the N right so you feed in uniform
bits and you're going to get some
probability distribution on 0 1 to the n
we are going to use C to denote this
probability distribution
as well as the circuit itself so a
circuit in our heads also represents a
distribution what is the distribution
whatever is the distribution that is
output on the uniform bits
all right so now we come to a complete
problem for sck
statistical difference is a complete
problem for sck and it's the following
promise problem
so the yes instances of SD have a tuple
C and D such that the statistical
distance between the distributions C and
D is at least two-thirds
the no instances of St are tuples C and
D such that the statistical distance
between C and D is at most one-third
okay and we note that SD is complete for
SEK under polynomial time many one
reductions
SD is also shown to be complete for SDK
under the more restrictive ac0 mini one
reductions and projection deductions
so statistical zero knowledge to us is
basically
This Promise problem statistical
difference
non-interactive statistical zero
knowledge nisek as the name suggests
these Protocols are essentially the same
as SDK protocols with the additional
restriction that the verifier must
accept or reject based on just a single
message from the approver so there is no
interaction between the prover and the
verifier and the decision must be made
just based on what the Brewer sends to
the verifier everything else Remains the
Same
to identify nisek we also look at a
complete two complete problems for nisek
the first one of which is called the
entropy approximation problem
so here consider a circuit C that takes
M bits of input and and outputs and bits
we identify with C also this probability
distribution on 0 1 to the n
E A is a promise problem
such that
on yes instances you have tuples C and K
so C represents a probability
distribution
case some threshold
so a yes instances a yes instance
satisfies that the entropy of C is at
least K plus 1. the entropy of C we
refer to the entropy of the probability
distribution that c entails
similarly a no instance of EA has
Triple C K such that the entropy of
X which is the same as C uh the
probability distribution has entropy at
most K minus 1. right so entropy
approximation sees the circuit whose
entropy we are trying to approximate and
K is the threshold which we are going to
either consider greater than K plus 1 or
less than K minus 1 as our actual
thresholds for the entropy
right and EA is complete for nisek under
polynomial time many one reductions it's
also complete for an isdk under ac0
manual reductions and projection
reductions so EA represents n i s e k
to us
we have another problem called the
support size problem which is also
complete for nisek under polynomial time
anyone reductions what is the support
size problem well here we are given a
circuit C and
a an integer s
the yes instances satisfy that
the output of the circuit is very close
to the uniform Distribution on n Bits
right so outputs of C have to be close
to uniform Distribution on end bits with
a statistical distance of at most 2 to
the negative s though no instances of
support size have CS such that the size
of the support of the distribution is at
most 2 to the N minus s
try to visualize this we look at this
diagram where on the left we have a yes
instance of support size observe that
the data that the probability mass is
spread almost uniformly over most of the
sample space
whereas for no instance on the right
observe that all of the probability mass
is concentrated on a very small region
of the sample space so essentially the
yes instances look like the uniform
distribution and the no instances look
very very far from the uniform
distribution
okay so what do we know about sck and
nisek
well sck is not known to be contained in
NP
non-triviality of sck and nisek gold
rate sahai and badan proved that sck is
not equal to promise BPP if and only if
n isdk is not equal to promise PPP so
promise BPP is this class of Promise
problems which have BPP type guarantees
on the yes and no instances and SDK and
nisek are either both strong or both
weak according to this result
here is a diagram and we observe that
SDK and NP there's no clear relationship
SDK obviously contains nisek and
co-nisek and that's where we stand
so what can we say about SDK and meta
complexity well there is a shared
history between these two Notions
um
we have the paper from allender and thus
which shows that mktp and mcsp are hard
for SDK under BPP Turing reductions so
these are hard problems for sck
we also have this result that says that
mktp is hard for co-n-i-sck under P poly
many one reductions this is a result due
to I'll enter Gover hirahara and Robel
further we also have this result by sax
and santhanam that says that for any
decidable promise problem l
if there is a BPP many one reduction
from L to RK recall that RK is this
promise promise version of K complexity
then
L is in sck so they give an upper bound
on problems that reduce to this uh
approximate version of K complexity
reductions to RK so previous attempts to
characterize complexity classes in terms
of reductions to RK have been
unsuccessful
they have been successful attempts in
either establishing hardness of problems
reducing to Arcade as in the AG HR paper
or in providing an upper bound on the
problems reducing to Arcade as in this
action Santana paper
our work has been successful in actually
establishing a characterization of
problems that reduce to RK
so what is our main result
our main result is a characterization
for nisek
for any decidable promise problem a we
are able to show that a is in nizek if
and only if
there is a RP many one reduction from a
to the promise problem RK
okay and what is the proof idea well in
One Direction we need to first show that
nisek has an RP many one reduction to RK
in order to do this we observe that it
suffice us to prove that entropy
approximation which is complete for
nisdk has such a reduction
so on the left we have
problem that deals with entropies of
circuits
and we are able to show that if a
circuit has high output entropy then
they usually print out strings of high K
complexity
whereas if a circuit has a small output
support size it always prints out
strings of low K complexity right and
that's what we see playing out on this
slide here so if we look at this
polynomially many outputs from the
circuit C under different random sheets
what aghr show is that if CSI entropy
then with high probability
the KT complexity of Y is higher than
some threshold
they also show that FC has a low support
size to start with then the KT
complexity of the output concatenator
output y has
some other threshold as an upper bound
and this threshold is smaller than the
previous threshold
right so because there is a gap
we are able to separate the yes
instances from the no instances based on
these upper and lower bounds
respectively
we showed that the same argument goes
through for K complexity instead of KT
complexity
so this establishes the first half of
the reduction uh first half of the
statement which is a reduction from
nisdk to RK
um and RP when you want reduction
what about the other direction well now
we need to show that there is an nisek
upper Bound for problems promise
problems that have an RP many one
reduction to the set RK
right and in order to show this we look
at the reduction from a to r k let M
represent the RP many one reduction from
a to r k for some promise problem a such
that M of x r is the query that is
generated by this reduction
um when we are considering X belonging
to uh the language to the promise
problem a
right so the main point is that this
distribution M of x r has low entropy if
x was a no instance for a and it has
high entropy if x is a yes instance for
a so you start with the yes instance and
the reduction generates a distribution
that has high entropy if you start with
a no instance the distribution the
reduction generates a distribution which
has low entropy
and the separation of entropy in this
yes and no cases is basically what leads
to an nisek protocol
and this protocol helps us resolve a via
this reduction to the promise problem RK
recall that entropy approximation is the
problem that deals with separating uh
entropies of a given circuit uh a given
probability distribution and that is
what resolves this issue here
this proof is due to sax and santhanum
who provide an SEK upper bomb but we
observe that nisek suffice us to resolve
this problem
moving on we also have a
characterization for statistical zero
knowledge
theorem for any decidable promise
problem a we show that a is an SDK if
and only if a has a BPP Boolean formula
reduction to RK
so these are probabilistic reductions
which generalize the notion of
non-adaptive truth table deductions that
is the reduction can make multiple
queries and also perform some
computation on the results of these
queries so these are more powerful
deductions than BPP many one reductions
which could only result in one query
um per input
so now we also have some results on The
Log space version of these classes so
consider an all-powerful proverb p as
before the verifier and simulator now
are restricted to being randomized log
space Turing machines
again we identify sckl and nistckl
with the complete problems for these
classes statistical difference uh
statistical difference on nc0 circuits
or entropy approximation on nc0 circuits
or branching programs and the reductions
that we consider now are either
projections or a projection manual
deductions or log space 21 reductions
we also have the following theorem that
for any decidable promise problem a a is
an n i s c k l
if and only if there are these
restricted reductions like uh a BP nc0
many one reduction from a to r k or an
RL minivan reduction from a to r k
and others
similarly we also give a
characterization for SC k l
so for any decidable promise problem a a
is an s c k l if and only if a has a log
space Boolean formula reduction to
statistical difference restricted to nc0
circuits or a has a BPL Boolean formula
reduction to RK so this is a
characterization for the complexity
class s c k l
finally we come to the discussion points
of discussion so the first point of
discussion is nisek versus nisek n
so a fact there are not many uh examples
of natural computation problems that are
known or conjectured to lie outside of P
where the class of problems reducible to
them via polynomial time anyone
reductions or log space 21 reductions
differ
so most of the natural computations
computation problems we have are such
that
both these classes under different
reductions look similar
so a question is
is it the case that the problems
reducible to RK via RP many one
reductions and RL 21 reductions do these
problems differ or should this be taken
as evidence that nisek and nisekl
coincide
so that's the first point of discussion
is to check if an isck is the same as
nisdkl and we hope that our reductions
uh shed some light on answering this
question
the next point for us is to consider
reductions to exact K complexity versus
approximate key complexity
so here's a fact no complexity class
larger than n c k l is known to be ac01
reducible to the exact kolmogorov
complexity function
so
what conclusion can we draw from our
results our results show that when the
reductions are considered to an
approximation of the call marker of
complexity function then n i s c k l is
essentially optimal
right so if we look at the reductions to
the approximate we have shown that n i s
g k l is the complexity class that is
characterized by these reductions and so
now it remains to
uh figure out what can be said about
reductions to the exact K complexity
function does it increase the complexity
class size or does it change the
complexity class or are we still in
nisek restricted to l
so that's another point of discussion
and the final point of discussion is we
suggest a potential Avenue for Attack on
the NP versus NL problem
right so let's start with the fact the
minimum call marker of Time problem the
problem of computing KT complexity lies
in NP
and it is hard for
co-n-i-s-c-kl under non-uniform
projections
what is the attack that we suggest if
mktp is in nijkl
then there must be a non-uniform
projection that takes strings of low KT
complexity and hence locate complexity
and Maps them to strings of high K
complexity
and simultaneously it also Maps strings
of high KT complexity to strings of
locate complexity
right so observe that this non uniform
projection seems to be taking low K
complex strings to high K complex
strings and simultaneously mapping High
KT complex strings to strings of low-key
complexity
right and this sounds a little bit like
a machine that is turning milk to water
and water to milk which we find
is probably unlikely and so the
potential conclusion that we can draw is
it is possible that one could show
unconditionally that such a projection
does not exist
among other things this would separate
NP from the class debt where debt is a
complexity class that contains NL and it
contains all problems that reduce to
Computing the determinant
right so if we could show that such a
projection does not exist then we are
able to separate NP from NL and this is
a potential Avenue for Attack on the
problem
we hope that our paper helps uh
strengthen the attacks on such a
question
and finally thanks for listening to the
talk and